hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast proin kefflin new biomarker
and novel window to kidney function
emerging new data for proline kefflin in
clinical populations my name is Scott
mater and I'm pleased to be your
moderator for this lab roots webinar
this event will be sponsored by Stingo
tech swing no tech is a biotechnology
company with innovative approach to
developing biomarkers for diagnosis
prediction and monitoring of acute
medical conditions such as heart failure
acute kidney injury and circulatory
shock in order to support patient
management and provide guidance for
treatment strategies swing go tech also
develops biomarkers for improved
prediction of health risks including
obesity cardiovascular disease and
breast cancer in order to support
prevention strategies for more
information please visit sphingo texecom
we have a few important announcements
before we begin the webcast is designed
to be interactive and we encourage you
to ask questions during the event you
can submit questions by typing them in
the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button in the
lower left hand corner of the
presentation window following the
didactic portion the program will have a
moderated discussion panel where we will
address attendee questions in the time
remaining you can enlarge the slide
window by clicking on the screen icon in
the lower right hand corner of the slide
window if you have any technical
problems viewing or hearing this
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of your
presentation window or submit your
problem through the green Q&A button
lower left this is an educational
webinar and thus offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
complete please click on the c/e button
located in the bottom left hand corner
of your web page and follow the process
of obtaining your credits I would now
like to introduce today's faculty
dr. Alan mazzella is professor of
medicine at the University of California
San Diego he's the director of the
coronary care unit at a heart failure
program at the VA San Diego health care
system in La Jolla California he is
considered a leading expert on cardiac
biomarkers and has over 300 scientific
publications to his name he has led
several groundbreaking multi-national
studies that have paved the way for
integrating biomarkers clinically
important as diagnostic tools dr.
Michelle is considered to be one of the
single greatest influences and
establishing an improved standard for
heart failure diagnosis with BNP testing
worldwide dr. olema lander professor of
internal medicine at Lund University and
consultant at the department of internal
medicine scone University Hospital Malmo
Sweden his research has focused on
improvement of cardiovascular risk
stratification and identification of
modifying non-modifiable mechanisms
behind diabetes and cardiovascular
disease the author of 372 original
scientific publications and Counting dr.
melander has been the recipient of
several investigational excellence
awards including the Peter Slade award
by the European Society of hypertension
force contributions to prediction and
prevention of cardiovascular disease
this brings me to today's first speaker
dr. Ravi menna is professor of medicine
at the University of California San
Diego School of Medicine's division of
nephrology an associate chair of
clinical research at the UCSD Department
of Medicine where he directs the
clinical nephrology and dialysis
programs dr. Matta is considered an
international authority and acute kidney
injury and has been integral to a more
refined understanding of the disease its
many complexities and evidence-based
management strategies I will now turn
the virtual podium over to dr. Mehta for
his presentation the need for novel
biomarkers and renal disease dr. Mehta
thank you Scott I appreciate the
opportunity to be with you
we'll try and put a profile of the
ensuing discussion on biomarkers but is
simply laying out what we currently know
and where we need to go these are my
find out disclosures for my for this
presentation I'm going to cover this
topic in three broad areas give you a
broad overview of AKI clicking knee
injury epidemiology describe what we
might need in the field and then discuss
the challenges and opportunities that we
have to put this first aspect in
perspective when we look at the global
burden of kidney disease you can see
here is that approximately in the United
States we are currently spending about 9
billion dollars a year for acute kidney
injury management 300,000 people die
from it annually and the length of stay
increases considerably and the overall
death rate per year is greater than the
combined death rates of prostate cancer
breast cancer huh trillion diabetes and
the odds of that increases quite
significantly when we go into a broader
perspective and look at the burden
across the world you can see that in the
high-income countries as you go from an
episode of acute kidney injury you can
have a significantly high mortality of
what ten to fifteen percent and then
consequently develop chronic kidney
disease and end-stage renal disease and
when that translates to low and
middle-income countries you can see the
magnitude of that burden is considerable
we are knowledge base in epidemiology
has been derived from multiple different
sources and has been enabled largely by
the development of the diagnostic and
and staging criteria which I will show
you in just a moment in addition we have
information on the hospital settings and
community setting and different disease
states in time insults and where it
occurs this has been enabled to a large
extent over the last two almost
14 year at 12 years by the introduction
of the rifle staging the akin
classification and most recently the que
digo classification for acute kidney
injury which are largely based upon two
primary criteria itself and that is it
change in creatinine and or a change in
urine output this change in creatinine
is measured over a course of seven days
and their staging criteria just reflects
the magnitude of change either as an
absolute criteria of about point three
milligrams per deciliter or 26 micro
moles per liter within a 48-hour
interval or a change off between 50 to
100 percent rise from a baseline within
seven days and this standing criteria
have been validated in over a million
patients in multiple publications in
fact restating criteria in a publication
be made in The Lancet last year
demonstrated that across the world there
is a significant burden of a kidney
injury as you can see in even remote
parts of Africa you have almost a
23-percent incidence of acute kidney
injury from the literature what this has
reflected in essentially is this this
finding that you have a difference in
the high-income countries and low-income
countries but the manifestation overall
is quite similar regardless of how you
get there a change in functional status
is what represents the chain lead our
ability to diagnose this disease and you
can see from the right hand and the left
hand panels here they change it in the
low-income and middle-income contrasted
with the high-income countries overall
what's important to recognize though is
that to a large extent we are
contributing to some of the burden of
kidney injury by the diagnostic and
therapeutic interventions that we need
to employ to take care of these patients
as you can see in this middle channel
middle panel at the column here there
are significant
relationships to Mar the most common
drugs that we calmly use and association
with different procedures one of the key
problems that we face obviously is what
happened after an episode of the kid
kidney injury and this cartoon shows you
possible scenarios where you have either
full recovery development of chronic
kidney disease or if you had
pre-existing connectivities beforehand
you would have a decline further or you
end up on end stage renal disease and
what is now well recognized is that if
you have chronic kidney disease it is a
major risk factor for kid kidney injury
and this there is a further decline and
a rapid progression with every episode
of acute kidney injury so that you can
hasten the development of its end stage
renal disease so in this background then
one comes the question is what's needed
and I think the first aspect here is
that we have to look at a patient you
need to determine if kidney damage is
occurred and what is its current status
the second is to define the nature of
injury and do we need to intervene and
then thirdly is to a certain prognosis
and define the follow-up now what tools
do we have currently in this conceptual
framework as you see the decline in GFR
which is the diagnostic criteria which
you currently employed is where we
detect kidney injury or we say somebody
has a problem but what you really need
to do is to look further to the left of
this and see where damage is occurring
and also the patients are at increased
risk to be able to identify them
consequently I take you back to the
disability diagnostic criteria you can
see that the criteria are still based
largely on a change in creatinine or a
change in urine output now what that
translates into is then you need to know
what was the reference creatinine
against which you are going to
demonstrate a change overall and when we
look at epidemiological studies to a
large extent we may not have that
information in a large number of
patients as shown as in this right
circles here
you can see that only about thirty to
forty percent of patients may have a
reference creatinine prior to admission
and this cartoon here demonstrates a
typical patient so as you can see in the
red dots and the red line this is
representative of a change in renal
function with a decline and as you can
see if you have a declining renal
function the detection by serum
creatinine occurs a little while later
than the actual decline because it is
reflective of a accumulation of the
creatinine so you are always lagging
behind the actual change itself and if
you take drug-induced renal injury as an
example you can also see that the
biomarker levels may reflect three
different different general courses and
acute event with an up and down amor
subacute atlant and then more chronic
toxicity which may reflect different
drugs which I will come to in a moment
and one of the key challenges we face in
this area is that we know that there are
precise definitions of a chronic kidney
disease which require a duration of
about 90 days and acute kidney injury as
I mentioned to you requires about seven
days that leaves this large segment in
between of acute kidney disease which is
in between these two episodes and this
is something that we still haven't had a
good good handle on these are the
classification and staging or chronic
kidney disease and the reason I show you
this is to reflect again on the fact
that a significant number almost about
thirty five percent of patients who come
with acute kidney injury will have
underlying chronic kidney disease
overall so we're fourth areas for the
challenges and opportunities that we
need to think about first is the time
course and exposure we know that
biological processes will always precede
a symptomatic phase and you can see here
in this cartoon that even in the setting
of a genetic predisposition there is a
biochemical phase which may precede the
functional impairment or be
concurrent with it and the amount of
damage cell death and repair will
dictate to large extent how we detect it
overall but we have the tools now to
detect this both in the urine and in the
blood depending upon what we are looking
at but as shown in this cartoon here it
depends upon the the efficacy of a
particular biomarker and the specificity
of where it will rise and also what its
trajectory will be so you can see that
depending upon when you measure it you
may catch a biomarker at its peak or
it's a decline so knowledge of the time
sequence of a biomarker therefore
becomes very important as is illustrated
in this slide here we are patients with
cardiac surgery and if you measure a
sequence of different biomarkers here
and recognize here that n gal and kill
one are reflective of damage and sister
fancy and creating a reflective of
changing function you can see the
trajectories on this here's creatinine
in the purple here systemc in the green
here is the end gal in the red and came
one in the blue their trajectories are
quite different when you measure them
and therefore one of the key things here
is timing after renal insult as to when
you apply a biomarker and as I've shown
you before the creatinine takes a little
longer to rise so an earlier time point
of detection would reflect of some
opportunity that you may be able to
intervene earlier a second-class pecked
therefore then becomes is can you detect
subclinical injury and well this cartoon
is demonstrating here is that if you
were able to use a biomarker to detect
the early phase before creating has
risen this gives you an opportunity to
know if damage has occurred or not and
what the relationship is so a few years
ago we had an ASCII consensus conference
and we came up with this with this
matrix if you were to use a functional
and a damaged marker together you might
be able then to classify patients into
one of these four boxes at any given
time point either they have only a
damaged marker elevator
such as Kim one around gal or you have a
functional marker such a society or
creating a urine output or combination
of both or none and therefore this wood
clamps classify them into different
categories and one of the more important
aspart then becomes is this would allow
us to change our current definitions
from just reflecting on VFR and damage
to have a collective and expanded so
that you could have either GFR or
geofoam damage or damage alone we
currently are not there because we don't
know what are the thresholds for the
biomarkers to detect damage and to be
able to validate it in large studies
there is some evidence that there is
metadata some some value to this in this
small study in the cardiology field if
you looked at n gallon film crafting
alone in this first panel here you find
it incidence of events and both are
negative is relatively know if you have
n gal positive and attracting negative
the indeed the incidence event goes up
if the N gal is negative that means
there's no damage attracting is still
positive suggested more of a functional
state on a pre real estate it is an
intermediate effect and it's both a
positive the worst effect what this also
amplifies to a large extent then is this
thought process that people are this is
a dynamic change you want to be able to
see as people move from one box to the
other because that helps you guide
therapeutic intervention and also for
the diagnostic strategies to demonstrate
the resolution is occurring or not in
that setting now we have a variety of
different biomarkers which are also
site-specific and these site specific
biomarkers then then can tell you the
site of injury can also help us map the
pathways of injury the difficulty is
obviously recognizing how these all
interact with each other and the
availability of these biomarkers for
regular use but in functional terms and
pragmatic terms what we really want to
be able to see is is there a
between a biomarker which is elevated in
somebody who had was otherwise healthy
versus someone who has underlying
chronic kidney disease and therefore a
combination of both a damaged and it's
functional marker may be of great value
in this setting and this slide
exemplifies to a large extent what
happens if you have unlined chronic
kidney disease at the bottom here you
can see that you have two two time
points a GF our patients the GFR less
than 60 gear for greater than 60 and in
each panel you have immediate post car
key polity bypass three hours 18 hours
and 24 hours and this is yearning and
gal as an example and what you can see
here is that the presence of a
underlying renal disease has some
elevation on the underlying biomarker at
baseline so these people regardless of
an insult will have a higher level
itself so they need to be take some
element of caution in terms of
interpreting these overall and what you
can see here is based upon the severity
and outcomes of this these biomarkers
you can establish some cut off so for
example for your an end gal less than
100 for our grades one hundred for may
have some prediction but these values
will change depending upon what the
population is overall in the United
States we have now a the only biomarker
which is currently approved is is a
combination of timp-2 and IDF insulin
growth factor binding protein seven this
is in currently being utilized overall
in in this in this setting and and we
hope that this will be something that
will become into more use overall now
the other aspect here is comorbidities
heterogeneity of AKI and in this slide
all I'd like you to focus on is the
panel a and panel be in panel a you can
see that the crease kitty perfusion
reflecting say a pre real estate is in
the put in the pink of pink line when
you look
patient is healthy with no aki worse
than the other extreme somebody with a
TN in the black line depending upon the
heterogeneity of what is happening you
have an influence on the specificity and
the area under the curve of Erie
biomarker so then the proportion of how
much there is a functional change
worsened damage will influence the
ability of a specific biomarkers and
identifying this process the second part
is the heterogeneity of aetiology if you
look at patients with the skinnier
reperfusion versus sepsis the sepsis in
the purple line is key miri preceding
the blue line the trajectory and the
peaks might be quite different in terms
of the threshold where this may be
established and then when you look at
the history Jenna T of background
function with normal versus no GF are
obviously as I've shown you earlier the
thresholds may vary in that time frame
itself so my last part here is
essentially the specificity of a chronic
drug induced injury and one of the key
things which happens here is obviously
looking at chronic toxicity and as an
example for this when you look at Satan
otha where the NOFA where we know very
specifically is where it is handled by
the country away by the kidney both with
respect to the oats transporters and
then also in the MRP to gene
transmutations and what we know here is
that the concentration of tanaka fair in
the mitochondria can cause mitochondrial
dysfunction and therefore over time lead
to an acutely sub acute injury which
progresses to chronic kidney disease in
that in that setting and therefore there
is now data obviously to suggest that if
you had biomarkers which showed you the
projection from one disease to the other
and you correlate with biopsies you may
be able to predict patients who have
these likelihood of these diseases this
cartoon just reflects again to some
extent the different biomarkers where
they are what they can do and how we
might be able to utilize them not only
for detecting cookie dingy but also
looking at
ditions overall just therefore to
summarize I think one of the biggest
areas so the opportunities are is to
think about these biomarkers as a
fit-for-purpose now this is the context
where the FDA and regulatory bodies look
at biomarker qualification and and for
for release and if you look at the
context of use these can be in these
five categories overall and this slide
is taken from the FDA and the biomarkers
consortium where you can classify
biomarkers in terms of identifying
success susceptibility and risk
diagnostic monitoring prognostic
predictive or pharmacodynamic profiles
now it's quite evident by looking at
this that is unlikely a single biomarker
will cover all of these aspects which
brings me to the point that in order for
us to use these biomarkers we may need
to think about them in terms of what the
purpose is now our particular biomarker
may fulfill more than one purpose but it
just has to be demonstrated in terms of
how that value is added to that change
but we are we are great opportunity
there to look at these in these contexts
itself my last slide just to summarize
what I hope I've shown you is that
certainly we are at a very exciting time
where we have a variety of different
biomarkers at individual panels that
shows and we can use them for a variety
of different with aspects of clinical
care and also however to do this we will
need to marry clinical data with dynamic
changes and obviously address the issues
of availability costs ease of use and
specific thank you for attention thank
you very much Robbie for that important
perspective on state-of-the-art care for
renal disease and the unmet needs where
biomarkers may play a role next I'd like
to introduce dr. Ellen May's L will be
presenting on proline kathlyn and its
role in acute kidney injury dr. Mayes L
okay thank you Scott ladies and
gentlemen thank you for joining today
I'm going to be talking on a novel
biomarker proem kefflin and its role in
acute kidney injury well just to
reiterate a small thing that was said
previously that aki is really a frequent
complication that occurs and maybe
one-third of everybody who comes into
the ICU and if you have septic shock
there's a fifty percent chance you're
going to have a ki and when this happens
the mortality may be up to fifty percent
so this is a huge problem now I'm a
cardiologist and in if you look at a mi
vs aki you can see the progression and
improvement of biomarkers we have had
over the years for acute myocardial
infarction and yet when we look at acute
kidney injury we really haven't had
anything except a marker that you heard
in the previous talk is not one really
rising quickly with injury so what we
really would like is a biomarker like a
troponin if you would and that you could
measure in the urine or the serum that
would really give you a early diagnosis
for early management and perhaps
development of new therapeutic
strategies so the five important
considerations for renal function
assessment again it should reflect the
renal function it should reflect real
time function rather than post renal
function like serum creatinine and
statistically it should be validated for
accuracy and precision in the clinical
setting you should be able to interpret
the results easily in the clinical
setting and it should have clinical
value so here is just a chart showing
the ones that are out there approved or
near approved and basically we don't yet
have the ideal kidney marker no other
alternatives can satisfy everything we
would want especially as was mentioned
is the serum creatinine so let's now
talk about pro and kefflin so Paul and
Kathleen first comes from and Catalan
Kevin we've known about for a long time
and it's a peptide hormone you can see
in the figures that's really abundant in
the kidney yet when you cannot measure
it is too unstable it's processed from
the prohormone Pro and Kevin and there's
a CNS derived in Kaplan which we know is
pain killers and then there's this non
CNS and this is a one that the heart and
the kidney release and these are ligands
of two different opioid receptors that
are highly abundant in the kidney now
Pro and careful enters we also call it
pent kid is a surrogate marker for in
kefflin that has key advantages it is
inflammation independent and it actually
it indicates the actual need for kidney
stimulation so it's very active now pen
kid proin kefflin measures the stable
component of its and catalan precursor
it's a stable fragment is the 119 to 159
fragment of the proem kefflin it's a
surrogate marker for the release of what
we'd like to measure in the past but
could never measure the real and careful
and peptides and you can now there's a
measurement available that is suitable
for clinical routine well let's look at
this slide here pen kid strongly
correlates to renal dysfunction and in
these two panels first you see a very
good correlation with creatinine and in
the second to the right you see a very
good inverse correlation with GF are now
if you look at prom kefflin and renal
function in clinical populations you can
stare is definite renal specificity with
the pen kid test this is a general
linearity model which shows the overall
pen kid levels that are reflected with
renal status there is a tenfold
difference in components with GFR versus
other predictors of pen kit and pen kid
levels are actually highest upon ed
presentation as a really solid
reflection of the cardial renal status
and the net reclassification in extra
pen kid for those that were graded low
risk yet had a maze was 18.1 so this
gives you information above and beyond
which you could normally obtain here's
some data to show the response of pen
kid in relation to real injuries on the
left side you can see that pen kid at
the cut point of 100 pyka mole per liter
will actually rise up to two days prior
to creatinine when a ki is present or
develops in my field of congestive heart
failure this is very important and will
lead me to a number of things that I
might do differently such as diuretics
ACE inhibitors things like this but even
more important perhaps is that this
marker can be used for monitoring aki
for the early recognition of kidney
normalization I can't tell you how many
times in my acute heart failure patients
and one-third get a ki that I have to
keep them in the hospital sometimes for
five or six days until the creatine
normalizes here you can get a nice
window several days before that the
paint kit drops and they will likely be
stable to send home thus saving
thousands of dollars in hospital causes
well let's now look at some studies of
pen kid in acute kidney injury first of
all let's just put this on the table
here that there has already you may be
hearing this for the first time but
there is broad validation and it is
growing there is studies in 18 countries
there's 23 clinical studies almost 700
study centers
and over 25,000 patients have been
studied already so this is not a
johnny-come-lately biomarker let me
start with one that we did at our own
institution with cardiac surgery because
we know this is a huge problem we sent
all my little residents and med students
to through the operating room early in
the morning in about a hundred patients
before during and after cardiac surgery
and we got samples and then looked at
who developed a ki in relationship to
the bio marker pen kit and again you can
see two different things here first of
all in people that developed a ki
post-op early from a bypass the pink kid
was elevated within six hours of going
on that pump secondly you can see that
before I without the pen kit it would
take up to two days or more before you
said oh my god the cranning zup they
suffered a hit to the kidneys I don't
need to tell you how important this can
be well let's look at some studies of
critically ill patients now and let's
start with a sepsis study that was
involved in taking place at my good dear
friend Sal de soma and kali gets up the
ends of University of Rome who looked at
a hundred won consecutive patients
coming to his emergency department with
status and enroll within 12 hours the
aki defined by the rifle criteria so
there's two things that we can see in
the left panel you can see that pen kid
increases with aki severity but is in
the normal range 0 and r are for risk in
septic patients without a ki now that is
because pen kit is independent from
inflammation now you cannot say this
like some of the other biomarkers angle
kim one all responsive to inflammation
which can make it difficult to interpret
the septic state and then on the right
side you can see that that admission
level of pink kid can predict seven-day
mortality in these patients admitted
with sepsis now let me show you just a
couple case studies to demonstrate how
serial testing is important to window
for renal function I as a biomarker guy
love cereal testing I don't want to work
with a biomarker that doesn't change in
response to treatment or condition and
here it does patient one had high levels
a pen kid the whole time they're above
normal died patient too had very high
levels at admission but with rigorous
treatment etc the pen kid levels dropped
in a normal range that patient survived
patient 3 started off with sasses but
was fine did not have hypen kid levels
but they develop during hospitalization
they died and finally patient for who
also has sepsis but never had any
peghead elevation survived what's more
in this next slide we can look how
serial testing can correlate to changing
prognosis and in this case mortality so
here on the left side you can see the
baseline first test a paint kid done in
the emergency room and what they did
then they took a subgroup with a high
levels of pink it and measured it four
days later and what was found that if
you did have a high level and it went
low you basically survived yet if you
hit a high level and it stayed high
there is a fifty percent chance you're
going to die I don't know about you I
want to know that information what we
would do about it we're not sure yet but
there's hints and those are targets at
drug companies and other device
companies may want to play into very
quickly another way to look at this is a
therapeutic goal right now
let's do whatever we can do to normalize
pain kid levels and sepsis patients and
you can see here in this study the green
those are alive over the hospitalization
and the gray shaded are dead if you can
normalize the pen kid levels you do
better your survival is better now
what's normal the studies have
demonstrated this is very easy to
remember number of 100 100 pyka mole per
liter is a great target now here's a
study of renal dysfunction in surgical
sepsis again 42 consecutive ICU patients
after major surgery who presented with
clinical signs of sepsis renal
dysfunction yes or no pen kid at a level
of 100 was a very robust differentiator
of renal dysfunction early renal
dysfunction in the setting of surgical
sepsis now this is going to be you're
going to hear a lot about this new study
frog I see you without several thousand
patients admitted to the ICU both sepsis
and non sepsis the data is just
beginning to be published but this is
really a rural bus observational study
on everybody who came to the ICU who
required either mechanical ventilation
for over one day or needed at least 24
hours of either basal pressors or inot
ropes and you can see the demographics
on the left side but really on the right
side again we seek confirmation of a ki
severity by the rifle criteria with pen
kid at levels of 100 and above the
levels do not go up in just those at
risk so inflammation is not an issue
otherwise the more severe it is the
higher depend kid levels let's look at
another famous study the pen kid in
severe sepsis and septic shock and the
famous album in Italian outcome sepsis
study or the LBO study this was a
substudy that sure that it shows a pink
it as a
marker of renal dysfunction it was a
multicenter randomized trial open-label
albumin versus crystalloid and patients
with severe septic or septic shock were
enrolled at 400 centers in here again
you can see a robust correlation with
presence or absence of kidney injury and
penn kid levels but also the need for
renal replacement therapy based on the
levels so if you get a high level be
prepared this patient could be getting
sicker and sicker in any intervention
you may be contemplating down the road
maybe we should consider early on and
then let's just take a look at in my
realm of cardiac disease in acute
myocardial infarction somebody doctor
engng colleagues demonstrating that pink
kid as a kidney dysfunction biomarker
can predict mortality and other
complications actually in acute
myocardial infarction this can be
extremely important and here we can look
at long-term mortality based on Turtles
of pen kid levels you could think of
things that you might want to do right
away in this setting in terms of how you
how much contrast you give for cardiac
catheterization what renal drugs you
might or might not use and what kind of
follow-up you would want for this
patient so finally this is a figure
similar but a little different than dr.
made a show looking at penn kid as a
real time marker and the potential to
augment the information we get from just
sarah gravity measurements so on the
left side you see screen not elevated or
elevated and a top peg kid not elevated
or elevated start with the lower left
box no aki risk your pen kid levels
normal your serum creatinine is normal
you're probably good to go what if
you're cracking is elevated but your pen
kid is not well this is likely a page
that already might have had some kidney
injury but is recuperating you come in
they come into the hospital they've been
sick for a few days and I kidney injury
but it's getting better we may not even
need to hospitalize this patient now the
top right is someone clearly that comes
in or you see a hike hike reading level
high pink a boom I think you have the
diagnosis acute kidney injury and at the
right you have a high pain kid but a
negative creating these are the ones I'm
very interested in especially my acute
heart failure patients for instance
because these are the ones I feel that
are going to be at risk for acute kidney
injury that we may be able to intervene
in so let me conclude about the growing
evidence based data that we have for pro
and kevlin or pink it first it's a
reliable surrogate plasma marker from
kefflin it's been clinically validated
in several thousand critically ill
patients both sepsis and an acute
cardiac disease it is not affected by
systemic inflammation and also other
comorbidities that we see in real life
like age and sex and things like that
it's got a simple cut off a 100 pi k
mole per liter that's been validated in
clinical settings the clinical utility
of pink it it can predict and diagnose
aki in the settings i showed you sets of
heart failure and it can monitor acute
kidney injury for early recognition of
kidney normalization and finally as with
any biomarker you always look at the
biomarker along with the clinical state
there is no substitute for hands-on
history physical examination empathy
compassion for the patient the
biomarkers are added to approve that
assessment you don't use the biomarker
by itself you merge the science with the
art of patient care thank you very much
I'll turn it back over to Scott Nader
thanks Ellen
we are beginning now to accrue a number
of questions from our listeners I want
to reinforce that if you do have a
question that Q&A box is in the lower
left-hand corner of your screen we will
following the next presentation we will
have a panel discussion world type try
to address your questions in the time
remaining now I'd like to introduce dr.
olema wander from London University
Medical Center to present his work on
pro in templin and the malmo health
study dr. Milano thank you very much
Scott and we're now going to move over
to from mainly critically ill or
severely ill patients to actually the
population and healthy subjects and I'm
going to show you some data that Pro and
carefully may actually be very good
marker also is at the population level
to predict the onset the future onset of
kidney disease of chronic kidney disease
see states are based on a large
population study from southern Sweden
I'd like to acknowledge my colleague
Christina shoulders the first author of
this paper was published in Jays and
earlier this year so I think I don't
need to convince you that the chronic
kidney disease is a growing public
health threat as you know it's not only
common but has been increasing over the
past 20 years or so and I think apart
from chronic kidney disease certainly
being a very potent risk factor for
going on to em stage renal disease we
have to remember also that it's a very
potent risk factor for developing
cardiovascular disease in cardiovascular
mortality so approximately eight to
sixteen percent of the population do you
suffer from chronic kidney disease and
is in the early stages just like
hypertension is not giving any symptoms
so awareness is low and the the etiology
of chronic kidney disease is partially
unknown but the cardiovascular risk
factors such as hypertension diabetes
and cluster metabolic abnormalities of
the metabolic syndrome are clearly
involved in them in the pathophysiology
and as I said being risk factor for
cardiovascular disease incidence and
mortality and as we previously heard for
hospitalized hospitalization and death
once you get ill so looking at by
measuring biomarkers in healthy subjects
but what is actually the clinical use of
death well I think I'm very fond of
primary prevention because when you are
sick it's usually too late to revert
that it's much more efficient to prevent
becoming sick so if for example if
you're in the GFR in the normal level of
GFR you should so there are several
things in lifestyle that you can do to
prevent development of chronic kidney
disease and again don't remember that
when you prevent chronic kidney disease
you will also thereby prevent
cardiovascular disease you may say that
anyone should adapt to healthy lifestyle
but I think those of you who are at
clinic active in primary prevention know
that this is tricky business so we do
have it do have a great potential value
of identifying that let's say hidden
high risk individuals in the population
and putting even greater efforts from
these people to adopt a healthy
lifestyle in order to prevent later
onset of chronic in disease and
cardiovascular disease what when you
move on to a to a slightly reduced level
of GFR it may if
you can maybe normally if the blood
pressure wouldn't be high maybe you
wouldn't go and treat that otherwise
healthy subject with antihypertensive
treatment but if you have a risk marker
you may say that well this patient is at
such high risk that we would actually
like to go on and reduce that excess
risk by creating the blood pressure at
lower levels then you would otherwise do
and and again this is not only about
preventing or saving your kidneys it's
also about preventing cardiovascular
disease so i would like to argue that if
you can identify hidden high risk
individuals even in this range of GFR
you could that could actually be
indication for lifelong statin therapy
and if you go to them too when actually
real when advanced renal disease or
chronic kidney disease is established we
need also to have novel treatments this
we don't have yet but this is part of
the talk that we can use the early
biomarkers to identify completely novel
treatment targets so on this slide i'm
just showing that chronic kidney disease
as you probably know has stages based on
album in urea and different levels of
declining levels of estimated GFR in
this particular study that will present
so we had a the level defining chronic
kidney disease at less than 60
milliliter per minute coming back to n
gasoline anchor pro and calf alien dr.
macer gave you an excellent overview of
why this peptide is interesting in in in
relation to renal damage and renal
disease and i have cited some of the
studies that were previously mentioned
in the Indy Indy critically ill patients
post post mi or during sepsis or septic
shock that's proactively in his
excellent marker to
digg acute kidney injury it may seem
from from a physiological
pathophysiological point of view a
little bit law a far away to start a
measure and key failing but there is
literature from quite a long time ago
this is a paper from 1987 actually
showing that injury McBay shins your
proactive or its or your met ANCA felon
levels active compound in plasma is
vastly higher in uremic patients than in
controls certainly at that time we think
that this may say this may only be a
retention effect due to the loss of
renal function and again this is why
it's important to find out whether an
kathaleen is actually causally related
to renal disease or not and I will come
back to that in a minute so the specific
aims of this study was to study if there
is a relationship between fasting level
of the pranky filling again in a healthy
population and the risk of going on
later to develop CKD or have a faster
decline of your EGF or over time and in
the second part of the study we wanted
to test whether this is the parallel
phenomenon related to filtration or
something else or whether it may
actually be a causal relationship
meaning that a high level of pro and
Kathleen may be causally related to
chronic kidney disease and for this we
used genetic methods that I will just
briefly give you results on in the end
so this is on this slide you can see the
clinical characteristics of the
population study from southern Sweden
that had a baseline examination in the
beginning of the 90s and that's where
that's where renal function was assessed
along with other cardiovascular risk
factors and we follow these subjects up
for prediction of
chronic kidney disease over a follow-up
period of approximately 16 years and
reassessed renal function at that stage
as you can see this population is around
56 years on the average and the
proactive funding levels if you compare
to the the previous presentations in the
critic lil where the cutoff is 100 Pike
moles per liter you can see as expected
that these subjects are considerably
lower in the mean values of proactively
and a little bit below 50 Pike moles per
liter in at this next slide I'm
presenting in in the entire study
population which is about 4,600 subjects
the clinical characteristics at the
baseline examination back in the
nineties in relation to being low lowest
tertile apparent kathaleen being in the
mid turtle or in the hiker turtle or
prank efully and as you can see as you
probably would expect aah is positively
related so that older you're the higher
oil levels of pouring gasoline but the
next clinical characteristics are a
little bit surprising at least they were
to us if you look at body mass index for
example so the higher your level of
prank if Elena's the lower will be your
body mass index the lower will be your
waist circumference your blood pressure
your glucose levels so these metabolic
features actually go in the opposite
direction because if you listen to it to
all the previous data you would
definitely think that they would go
higher with a dis metabolic state but
for and again these are the cross
sectional baseline data with increasing
/ and carefully level low medium high
turtle well your serum creatinine
curtain is definitely higher sister in
sees higher the estimated GFR is
definitely lower so that
makes a lot of sense in relation to the
the critically ill patients on the on
this slide you will see the longitudinal
change of egfr in groups of people who
at the baseline had a low medium or high
levels of pro enkephalin and here you
can see if you remember the rather
surprising relationship with metabolic
traits so that the higher or your level
the higher levels of pro enkephalin is
the the lower will be the increase of
waist circumference and also the lower
will be the progression of your
diastolic blood pressure and same thing
with glucose decreases bath yet the
decline of egfr if you look here you see
that clearly those people are the high
level of the proactively and at the
baseline over this follow-up period they
have a significant those who have high
levels of pro and carefully have a
significantly greater fall or decline in
their estimated GFR during these sixteen
years of follow-up again if we then look
at the fasting level of pro and
carefully in in relation to the risk of
in in all and of course at baseline
these subjects were all free of chronic
kidney disease and the risk of going on
to develop incident chronic kidney
disease during the follow-up period the
risk of doing that if you're in the top
tertile of priyanka philly and at the
baseline you have a 50-percent increased
risk an odds ratio 1.5 to go on and
develop new onset chronic kidney disease
which is highly significant it's highly
significant in crude in mildly adjusted
fully adjusted models and then we need
of course to if we want to use a
biomarker to identify let's say hidden
high risk we need to some way also
clinically evaluated that one way of
doing that as as is the the area under
the ROC curve this is a very poor way of
doing it in long in in long-term
prediction this is an excellent way in
diagnosis and short term prognosis but
not during 16 years of follow-up here
you would rather like to have to find
hidden high-risk individuals and this is
what we can get the measure of by using
the so-called net reclassification
improvement so when we added pro
enkephalin on top of all the risk
factors for CKD that we already know of
we could unmask about forty percent of
these people who weren't on to develop
chronic kidney disease as well as as
also down classifying people who were
falsely who were put at falsely high
risk by the traditional risk factors so
this means that we can actually identify
if you allow the expression hidden high
risk individuals for CKD by measuring
the fastening levels of priyanka filling
in the next slide we were encouraged to
look at whether this is more important
in the jungle part of the population on
the older part in population and we
actually found that there was a highly
significant interaction between pro
enkephalin level and the age of the
subjects and this means on regarding the
the strength of the relationship on
chronic kidney disease as you can see
here the the discriminatory value of the
association between high priyanka Faline
and poor decline or rapid decline in gfo
or high risk of CKD is much stronger in
the young patients in older part of the
population this is probably blunted by
other age-related factors so if you want
to use proactively to predict chronic
kidney disease it's its best use is in
the more healthy and younger subset of
the population finally we were very
interested to find out whether this is
causal or not this means that we already
know as I showed you this is just
expressed per standard deviation change
that fasting pink is related to the
independent risk factor of incident CKD
so we did a genetic screen a genome-wide
Association studies and don't get
confused now this is not saying that all
that we are finding here is genetics
know genetics explains just a tiny
proportion of pro enkephalin levels but
by identifying a genetic component of
pro enkephalin we can use that small but
very very significant effect of the
proact of genetic profiling to study
where they're pranking levels are
causally related to chronic kidney
disease so a we identified the strongest
genetic factor in the gene of pro
enkephalin and which elevated prank
feeling slightly but very very
significantly and then we tested whether
this genetic elevation which is not at
all confounded by a lot of environmental
factors that we have to deal with with
life when measuring lifestyle factors or
commonly also in a plasma biomarkers and
what we found was that the genetic
elevation was actually significantly the
genetic elevation of proin carefully and
was significantly related to the risk of
chronic kidney disease so this is a
strong evidence that not only can we use
proactive Lina's as a predictor of
chronic kidney disease it's also likely
to be
causally related to chronic indices
because they were otherwise the genetic
component wouldn't be related to disease
incidence so I like to conclude by
saying that reminding that we have now
quite strong evidence also apart from
the critically ill we know in the
population that prank Italian predicts
the onset of later chronic kidney
disease later in life so and we have
shown that you can actually identify
hidden high risk individuals and you can
do something about that because you can
at an earlier stage go in and treat
blood pressure you can do it intensified
lifestyle therapy and you may even
consider statin therapy because of the
comorbidity later in life with
cardiovascular disease and in the last
part which is a little bit more for the
future I showed you that the genetic
approach showed that that the plasma
concentration of Franklin is likely to
be causally related to development of
chronic kidney disease and this is not
only of academic interest because what
it suggests is that in the future we may
be able because of these causal evidence
we may be able to block any causal
effects of proactively and with new
drugs and thereby maybe use these drugs
in people who are sick maybe and even
the further in the future to use as
preventive medications so ladies and
gentlemen I'd like to thank you for
listening very much thank you thank you
very much only and excellent
presentations from all of our faculty
presenters would like to we are at the
top of the hour and we do have a few
minutes where we can entertain a few
questions that have come in and I'd like
to go ahead and move directly to that
the the questions that have come in the
first one I'd like to talk to the group
about is
them a question that's regarding the
integrating this test into clinical
practice we've obviously seen a lot of
emerging data that has come out there is
a great deal of data that is underway
with this product but from the data that
we've seen I'd like to turn it to our
panel maybe a rommie as you have
presented that the need for biomarkers
and you've an acquaintance with the data
that our faculty of presented on prime
chaplain do you have any thoughts on how
this product might be integrated into
clinical practice from you know with the
with the information that we have yes
god I think that both Allen and all they
have presented the application of pen
kid in clinical practice and as you can
see its value adds to my mind would be
more in defining a change in renal
function prior to an elevation of crap
means in a sense it is a functional
marker which is more more precise and
more timely than creatinine currently
and what Allen pointed out was in his
for matrix was essentially it might also
reflect a resolution of kidney injury
earlier than creatinine might reflect
and as always pointed out is if it is
reflective of downstream changes then it
can be a risk profile marker which
allows you to pay more attention to
patients with this so I think in all in
all its application will need to be
defined further as we go with for the
studies but the results we have here and
it's its ability to discriminate despite
the setting is a very very important
area thanks very much for that that
comment i think that captures things
nicely maybe Alan the the comments that
Robbie mentioned about this being a
functional marker the the kinetics of
its availability in blood and its
presence in blood in real time how is
how do you see this in acute kidney
well I think first of all you can if
you're in Europe you can obtain this
right now there's kids available I think
in the United States there's still some
development left to do I know there's
some very important labs that are taking
this on and studying this in the United
States and I hopefully one day soon
they'll be available in either essays or
point-of-care obviously if you're
dealing with Aki you would like not to
have to wait too long for that
information so the quicker you can get
it the better you will be able to handle
it as a cardiologist I very much can see
this being of use in my acute heart
failure patients and when they come in
the ER determination of aki ando aki
might tell me how what kind of diuretics
i'm going to use whether i should
withhold ACE inhibitors whether they
need to go for angiography should we try
to delay the contrast or not a whole
host including where I put the patient
in the ICU versus the floor certainly
i'm not going to discharge somebody from
the ED that has a heart failure and
impending kidney injury is elicited by a
high pen kid level do you view this is
you know you've mentioned heart failure
your you are a clinical focused you see
this is part of a panel I know you've
developed biomarkers in that category
well yes I do and you know we're hopeful
with the angle it hasn't quite panned
out for heart failure but yeah we really
need besides an injury the nature attic
peptide-1 for infection fibrosis biomart
whatever where there's a panel but I
would always include if we could a
marker what we always get creating but
something that would be elevated before
[ __ ] hey I think this would be yeah
you know five years from now this will
be part of every workup for acute acute
heart fair very good only any comments
that you'd like to off right now your
conclusions kind of your conclusion
slide suggests so some place where this
product meets clinical need the occur to
expand or comment further right I mean I
completely agree we're all now and and
and I think that this this is definitely
a
ready for use in the critically ill and
in these settings and but if you look at
many other bar I mean take Alan's old
from BMP I mean we're using it now for
risk prediction in the population so
what I presented probably will come a
little bit later but I'm pretty positive
that they will come I also think that
for risk markers I have learned that we
will I mean for in the population
especially you don't want them to
correlate with all the already known
risk markers pen kid is inversely
correlated with all the tradition
traditional risk factors apart from
renal function so I think it's going to
have a big values at the population
level for finding risk individuals very
good thank you very much panel I'd like
to ask another question that came in it
is related to the question about this
you know obviously some of the data
presented the the Frog ice you study
sell the soma study Allen of the malmo
study in particular these large studies
in European soil while there has been
some us stuff presented today is there
more data coming available on penn kid
tested in u.s. populations and Ellen
won't let directors sure yeah yeah
thanks for that I mean already twenty
five thousand patients have been study
but I assure you there are many many
data banks and studies that are being
completed at this time I'm using pen kid
is a diagnosis and a risk predictor you
will see a number of very good I feel
excellent papers published probably
within the next 6 12 months so that did
there's a treasure trove of data being
mined currently I in the United States
very good the and and Ravi I don't know
if you have any any thoughts or comments
as a US investigator and
and clinician but certainly this is an
area of great exploratory do you have
any areas with us populations you'd like
to see this well I think that I think
one of them one of the areas which ties
into all of this is essentially not only
for diagnosing a kidney injury but
predominantly to look and see what
happens in the recovery phase because if
the connection from aki to see Kady is
as robust as we are finding it to be
then finding a biomarker which not only
predicts whether you are at risk for or
have developed it but in terms of are
you resolving from it or are you likely
to get CKD becomes an important
perspective in which to evaluate it
mm-hmm very good thank you very much you
know one other comment I will make and
that is you know only I know you're the
malmo study was listed in fasting
fasting plasma that was that was part of
the malmo study and not not part of the
requisites for a pen kid testing correct
exactly no III don't I mean there are
many fire marcus's related to metabolize
of course that need to be taking the
fastest day but but for 10 / on
carefully and that that's not a that's
not a criterium it's it was just part of
the design of the study just like you
said very good very good we are 10
minutes past the hour I want to thank
all of our attendees for staying with us
through to this point I'd also like to
reference for those attendees who did
have questions we haven't gotten to we
are able to address those after the fact
and we will we will direct them to
appropriate faculty and respond
privately as lab roots does have your
contact information directly also we are
looking forward to having more
information on this come available I'd
like to finally thank lab roots and
thank our
faculty doctors Mademoiselle melander
the 3 m's for your outstanding
contributions to our better
understanding of pro in kefflin thank
you all very much for your participation
today and we look forward to meeting
with you again in the future another lab
roots winner thank you